DAN GALPIN: Hi.
I'm Dan Galpin, Android
developer advocate.
And we're here to talk about
the Android 7.1 preview.
A couple of weeks
ago, we announced
that a developer preview
of Android 7.1 Nougat
was on the way.
And just in case you haven't
noticed, it's available now.
There's a few differences
between this preview
and others in the program.
Since 7.1 is already
launched on Pixel,
we're delivering the
initial developer preview
at beta quality for the
Nexus lineup of devices.
The goal is to tease out
any device-specific issues.
This means we've already
finalized the new APIs as API
level 25, and we've
opened up publishing
on Google Play for apps
targeting the new API level.
So you can update your apps
as soon as you're ready.
So what's new?
First of all, Android 7.1
features a few changes
specific to the launcher.
App shortcuts allow you to add
both static and dynamic links
to key actions within your app.
Users simply long press
your Apps Launcher icon
to reveal the app
shortcuts, then
tap on a shortcut to jump
to the associated action.
Each shortcut references
an intent, each of which
launches a specific
action or task.
And you can create a
shortcut for any action
that you can express
as an intent.
For example, you
can create intents
for sending a new text
message, making a reservation,
playing a video, continue
game, loading a map
location, and much more.
You can create shortcuts
for your app statically
by adding them to a
resource file in the APK,
or you can add them
dynamically at runtime.
Static shortcuts are
ideal for common actions,
and dynamic shortcuts
let you highlight
actions based on
user's preferences,
behavior, location, and so on.
You can offer up to five
shortcuts in each of your apps.
After your app adds
shortcuts, they're
available on any launcher
that supports them,
such as the Pixel
Launcher, the default
launcher on Pixel devices,
the Now Launcher, the default
launcher on Nexus devices,
and other launchers that
provide support.
Any app can create shortcuts,
and any launcher app
can add support for shortcuts.
Android 7.1 provides
an API for apps
to register shortcuts
and launchers
to read the
registered shortcuts.
Apps can now define circular
launcher icons which
are used on devices that
support them, and much of this
happens automatically.
When a launcher
requests an app icon,
the framework returns
either Android colon icon
or Android colon round icon,
depending on the device
build configuration.
You can use Image Asset
Studio to design round icons.
You can test your circular
icons on a Google Pixel device
or by running the Android
emulator with the Google API's
emulator system image
targeting API level 25.
Something that feels
related to the launcher
is enhanced live
wallpaper metadata.
In addition to the existing
metadata attributes,
such as label,
description, and author,
there are new attributes
for a context URL and title
to link users to
more information
about the wallpaper.
This allows for a better,
richer user experience
when choosing live wallpapers.
Another 7.1 feature makes
stickers and other rich content
available through soft
keyboards, otherwise known
as input method editors or IMEs.
The 7.1 SDK includes
the Commit Content API,
which provides a universal
way to send images
and other rich
content from an IME
directly to a text
editor in an app.
The API i also available in the
revision 25 version of the V13
support library.
With this API, you can
build messaging apps
that accept rich content
from any keyboard
as well as keyboards that can
send rich content to any app.
There are two other
cool things in 7.1
that you might want to
consider taking advantage of.
The first of them is the
storage manager intent.
Apps can now fire the action
manage storage intent,
taking the user to the
system's Free Up Space screen.
If your app requires more space
than is currently available,
it can use this intent to
let the user delete unneeded
apps and content to free
up sufficient space.
Another thing you can take
advantage of in your app
is checking to see if
the device is running
as the demo user using
the new user manager
is demo user method.
This allows your
app to customize
the starting experience
to a potential customer.
When running as a
demo user, an app
might provide more
assistance to the user
or explain its features
in more detail.
There are a bunch of
other features in 7.1,
such as support for additional
Android Wear [INAUDIBLE]
and some important
telephony features.
Check the Android 7.1 page
out on developer.android.com
for all the details.
If you're already enrolled
in the Android beta program,
then your eligible
enrolled devices
will get the Android 7.1
developer preview update
right away.
No action is needed
on your part.
If you aren't yet
enrolled in Android beta,
the easiest way to get started
is to visit Android.com/beta
and opt in your eligible
Android phone or tablet.
You'll soon receive
this and later
preview updates over the air.
If you have an enrolled
device and do not
want to receive the update,
just visit Android Beta
and unenroll the device.
You can also download in
flash this update manually.
We welcome your feedback in the
developer preview issue tracker
and preview developer community
or Android beta community
as we work towards the
consumer release in December.
[MUSIC PLAYING]